um you know we just wanted to start the
conversation
i think i think we lost it you sure yeah
we lost it
wait can you guys still cause i see us
still live on the screen
i see they're laughing
i see ron's laughing wait
it says the meeting was
ah
can you hear us
can someone raise their hand if they can
hear us
it's still working for me it's just you
were lagging during that question yeah i
can hear you i'm fine
i'm laughing at you just you know
i think it just cut you off after your
fifth sentence each time and then it got
back into it
okay thank you paul all right i'm gonna
keep it real short
what do you love about independent film
i think i think now we did lose it
because it's all frozen across the board
damn
i wonder if our internet's not fast
enough
that's a bummer i wonder if we just
dropped and maybe they're still yeah i
think they're still theirs
all right um
oh he got scared
all right it'd be funny if like we can't
get into our own hangout
up all right all right
we're getting re-situated here everybody
my goodness
i'm with you ross i might have to cut
out as well yeah
if you guys could youtube looking would
you
damn it
well it has some growing pains that's
for sure why internet's not the same
i think it's more around
oh geez
no it's funny we go we got
we got locked outside
oh that's too funny
it's already like full of these people
that's great that's really funny